yeah and the the panel that Pearl's  talking about we're gonna talk about  that I'm actually gonna audience I'm  gonna cover that full panel for you  you're gonna see more control in that  catalog bad day oh yeah but essentially  like what was that experience because  it's a channel you show up it's supposed  to be feminist anti-feminist was it  edited tell me about it oh it was so  edited oh let's let's talk about the  libs on that panel so first there's only  two real conservatives let's be honest  you can't you can't be you can't be Pro  BLM and like super conservative so they  gave us four only it was really just me  and Sydney against the world shout out  Sydney and and it was actually six hours  we were there total so I don't know how  much we filmed I guess like three four  hours we were filming so maybe like hour  post hour before I don't know and that's  cut down to what an hour it was cut down  a lot 45 minutes oh